sulle persone che hanno l'attaccatura
dei capelli in un certo modo non ce
l'hanno tipo dietro il cielo qua perché
io quando inizio un video porca eva devo
essere così perché sempre sempre need is
like degli haters che mi fanno avere i
capelli così fantastico sticazzi è da
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono favi già oggi siamo tornati su dent
the town red che è stato aggiornato un
sacco di volte perché dalla vita non lo
faccio e quindi ci sono i livelli degli
utenti che una figata skyrim dragoes
riceva bene poi abbiamo minchia traggono
si dice veramente inizierò con skyrim
che figata ma come vestito ciao ragazzi
di dragoes lì ci sono dovahkiin come
siete tutti belli incazzati che non
aspettate altro che io vidi a un pugno
trovato questo posso infilatelo
nell'occhio non adesso perché devo dare
un'occhiata in giro che belli tutti
questi vestiti poco eterosessuali eccolo
qua lo ial
vabbè ragazzi allora basta gatto
comparire i miei video lo so che vuoi la
fama basta di reni iniziare a picchiare
lo jarl però tutti quanti se picchio lui
sicuramente si rivolteranno contro però
jolo
io non ti ho colpito zio non ti ho
colpito non ti ha colpito
adesso tocca al pd ha dato questi sì me
si menano da soli per quale cazzo di
motivo lo sanno solo loro a posto frate
si mena si meranda soliti perché
viminate da soli ma avete un regalo
porca vacca volo non va giù marchiava o
non muore impossibile mi sono pagato in
mano strada
altro che fossero da allora signori o
trova il modo di uscire questo ce la
faccia felice perché mi orquera
sicuramente adesso non è più felice
fatemi capire dove devo andare non ho
capito su stiletti forquet amato è
finito berserk molecola faccia a tutti
ma porca eva altro che skyrim rocky iv
tonucci 12 eto'o a pugni
aiart l'ho sentita questa un attimo che
doveva quanto vi do cazzo
no non mi toccano né toccare che muoio
con tre mancano i ragazzi stop sono
veramente morto e troppa poca vita forse
la mazza può aiutarmi e non intendo
quella vera ok ok ma quant'è forte sta
mazzata bard cavalli trick shot e via di
arance piatto per sasha a quella madonna
poi mi sono caricato forte no alla luce
dell'ultima non può uccidermi lui che
culo non era lui raga ma quanti sono
mario massacrati tutti e che vivo non è
possibile o tipo i livelli che scarichi
non finiscono tipo che fino crowd
something lancia qualcosa texture frego
pamela e pazienza sono contento lo
stesso brindiamo ai cadaveri
va bè ragazzi proviamo un rock concert
questo era questo lo curiosissimo di
vederlo da prima
salve voi non ascoltate justin bieber e
no questa non gli piace high school
musical a questa gente prova odio sembra
fabric ma come sentite eco al play sono
fa vj fa anche rima senti posso fare
parte della band e io so cantare guarda
qua soldi in mano da un assegni il mio
culo sopra una bentley big babol sto
fumando ferro in mano come il rambo v
aspetto fuori ragazzi e vi aspetto fuori
vediamo subito l'utilità di questo
poliziotto barra bodyguard vediamo
quanto serve
buti utilizzi york aveva beffa se
proprio inutile non è sì però polizia mi
aggredisce bravi
no no no tu sei il cantante non puoi
fare brutta figura poi finisce sui
giornali
no no qual è la tua band perché
d'argento 76 vestito servizio è cosa è
successo marcello picchiarci mi and expo
accompagnare solo ai acquisti che va
basta questo di ciampa di tutti sembrava
mio zio nova deragliano ci avrò mai
troppa poca vita c'è troppa gente
fus roda fanno la maiala è quanta gente
tutti che il 100 di scemi e vabbè ci
prova nicchia quanti ce ne sono 100 ma a
voi siete terrò gati forte aveva 100
però mai vai replay lever le prove
l'ultima volta ragazzi solo per capire
series ma mica cento sono troppi
iniziano già iniziamo male per chiedere
sempre più che si è vestito di merda
cercava cosa è successo alla porta
signori tanti auguri
ma la vera che è impossibile ciò sono i
film sono i feed aiuto a verde o morto
svenuto ragazzi sto facendo peggio di
prima
sulle mani milano avete mica delle armi
da prestarmi ragazzi grazie marcava che
[ __ ] scusa non volevo
che musicista signori che musicista cavo
bong a forchia vacca strike e la madonna
aiuto ma sono spider man così
come come sono o no vabbè sono incerti
100 posti dato 100 uomini cazzate al
concerto infatti di acidi e sono morto
perché sono inciampato su delle casse
la vera che ha tanto era impossibile ha
fatto 26 su 100 e mi sono impegnato pure
basta ma va bene così sono con te è
stato bellissimo
spero che questo gioco l'abbiate
rivalutato dopo questo video se non è un
gioco dell'anno questo non so io però
che vi sia piaciuto è stato bello bello
altro che poco sia piaciuto ragazzi
quasi 200 momento mi piace anche a vari
social come iscrizione nel senso che si
scateni ci vediamo al prossimo video ad
un prossimo concerto quello che da
ragazzi
[Musica]